paris xiiie arrondissement
ce méthane est quelque peu stressé unis
raisons spéciales est attendu devant la
mairie palette carton 220 mille masques
sont arrivés de chine
ce mardi du coup ça admire à la mairie
du 13e la mairie de val dispatchés dans
les différents organismes
donc petit à détruire le piano puis
détruire que le plus grand centre
hospitalier de l'europe d'europe la
caserne masséna la caserne des pompiers
le différend est pas d éventuellement si
nous en reste
différents hôpitaux de la région
parisienne et attention en manutention
fait les genoux qui travaille fait pas
le dos 95 carton en plus de ces huit
palettes cent mille autres masques sont
attendus d'ici lundi prochain pour un
total qui atteint 320 milles derrière
cet élan de solidarité 46 donateurs
entreprise franco chinoises association
en douchynoise sans oublier de généreux
particulier faire jouer ses relations
pour aider le personnel soignant à
l'instar des bénévoles venus de paris et
de sa banlieue qui ont répondu à
plusieurs appels lancés sur les réseaux
sociaux
ces dernières 24 heures on a ressenti le
besoin d'aidé depuis le début on est
confiné on se soit pas forcément très
utile donc là c'est une initiative pour
pour aider c'est très simple c'est que
vous avez un talus et tout à l'heure
jack est très actif dans la communauté
et mon voisin de palier donc il m'a
demandé si j'étais disponible j'ai dit
ouais bien sûr évidemment c'est mon
métier aussi d'aider les autres donc
lâché au chômage technique et du coup
garder le moral de pouvoir a aidé voilà
pour faciliter cette livraison les
bénévoles ont sollicité gérard darmanin
ministre de l'action et des comptes
publics notamment pour obtenir la
suspension des droits de douanes de 6 5%
sur ce type de matériel
une initiative parmi d'autres en vue de
pallier la pénurie de masques constatée
depuis le début de l'épidémie